[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle émission les 7-8 les invités
une émission vous savez pour découvrir
celles et ceux qui font l'actualité dans
le département et ce soir paroles à
joséphine coleman ce berger la mère de
plaisir et première vice présidente de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines
elle présentait il ya quelques jours le
projet de territoire de l'agglomération
un projet dont l'objectif est de
façonner l l'avenir de l'agglomération
dans de nombreux domaines
dans cette émission nous rencontrerons
également nina miolane l'une des
lauréates de la bourse l'oréal unesco
pour les femmes et la science la jeune
chercheuse
originaire de guyancourt travaille sur
un modèle numérique de l'anatomie
humaine transports développement
économie logement déplacements
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines planche sur son avenir la
semaine dernière a été présentée au
théâtre de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
le projet de territoire qui doit donc
façonné l'agglomération pour les
prochaines années
joséphine comme hans berger maire de
plaisir les premières vice président de
l'agglomération et est en charge du
dossier et nous explique ce qu'est le
projet de territoire au micro
d'haussmann wandern et donc bonjour
alors ce projet de territoire et que
vous tient à coeur
pourquoi parce que c'est indispensable
je crois que la création de cette
intercommunalité de cette agglomération
à 12 mérite véritablement que nous
mettions en place un projet territoire
c'est-à-dire une projection sur les
trente à quarante années qui viennent en
quelque sorte c'est une feuille de route
d'actions prioritaires et dax l'ambition
pour notre net pour notre territoire
alors à quoi peuvent s'attendre les
saint quentinois ce soir ou plus tard
écoutez justement si c'est ça qui est
bien c'est qu'on va les écouter on a un
bureau d'études qui va nous accompagner
et nous allons travailler en partenariat
étroit avec les saint quentinois avec
les entreprises des associations tous
nos partenaires qui font véritablement
partie aujourd'hui du territoire
c'est avec eux que nous allons
construire puisque c'est pas quelque
chose qui va se faire dans un bureau
c'est quelque chose qui va se faire en
partenariat et en écoute de leurs
attentes
et c'est à partir de là que nous allons
créer projet territoire alors ses
attentes c'est à travers internet
on peut dire ce qu'on souhaite sur les
réseaux sociaux expliquez moi un petit
peu il va y avoir peut-être un peu tout
ça mais je pense qu'on sera plutôt en
information directe avec des ateliers
des tables rondes pourquoi pas des
séminaires des rencontres véritablement
en lien direct avec la population et
avec les partenaires
moi je serais ravi de rencontrer les
entreprises
et puis aussi l'université et pourquoi
pas les associations je disais tout à
l'heure tous a aussi en lien et en
partenariat avec le codes skis puisque
le codis qui sera partie prenante aussi
de cette réflexion on a besoin je dirais
comme on va vers quelque chose d'humain
puisque le projet territoire de se
positionner sur de l'humain et sur des
attentes humaine il faut aller au devant
de la population
donc c'est un projet aux environs sur 30
ans on va parler des bus des habitations
dites moi un peu plus on va parler du
développement économique on va parler
les transports on va parler de l'habitat
de l'aménagement du territoire au niveau
commercial industriel du bien-être du
bien vivre des espaces verts de tout le
maintien de notre équilibre du rural
urbain que nous avons la chance d'avoir
sur notre territoire alors vous me direz
pas on a déjà tout ça oui on a déjà tous
à 7 mais pas à 12 et à 12,2 territoire
s'agrandit et donc c'est ce projet là
qu'il faut faire apprendre à travailler
ensemble apprendre à fédérer nos actions
d'autres potentiels et nos ambitions
pour créer quelque chose
encore une fois je le répète ensemble
vous l'avez dit on et + 7 mai 12
maintenant c'est pas compliqué de
travailler tous ensemble
10 et c'est pas toujours très simple
mais c'est passionnant ça prouve que
nous avons des des envies différentes
des histoires différentes
il faut reconnaître que les sept villes
on va dire historique
ça fait 40 ans qui sont dans ce système
d'agglomération alors que nous pas du
tout donc on arrive je dirais dans une
organisation tout à fait différente il
faut s'écouter se respecte et c'est pas
toujours simple voilà des fois c'est un
peu vifs mais on arrive toujours à avoir
des conclusions plutôt positive 2016
2017 c'est une année importante
il ya plusieurs étapes vous pouvez me
les décrit un petit peu oui il ya trois
phases alors la première phase commence
là au mois de décembre puisque
aujourd'hui c'est grand lancement
officiel donc de décembre à mars on va
faire tout ce qui y est diagnostic
on a déjà énormément de choses puisque
50 avait déjà beaucoup travaillé la
casse qui à l'époque avait déjà beaucoup
travaillé sur des études par rapport à
ce diagnostic
et puis les 7 communes aussi apporte des
choses qui sont déjà bien travaillé à
partir de mars on va travailler à
l'élaboration c'est là que vont avoir
lieu bien sûr tout six rencontres dont
je vous parlais précédemment
et ensuite il va y avoir la présentation
de ce projet à partir du mois de juin et
après la chose la plus importante c'est
la mise en application qui sera à partir
de septembre octobre avec bien sûr
l'aval de tous les élus des douze maires
et de tous les conseillers
communautaires
donc il va falloir passer par les 12
maires ils seront tous d'accord il y en
a certains qui sont pas très sûrs je
pense qu'aujourd'hui peut-être tout le
monde ne comprend peut-être pas
complètement l'enjeu qui peut y avoir
parce que déjà il ya énormément de
choses qui se font ces très riches
donc pourquoi peut-être s'appesantir
avec un projet territoire mais par
expérience pour avoir pu constater dans
d'autres secteurs dans d'autres espaces
en france les projets territoire et ils
ont mené à des choses beaucoup plus
concrète avec avec cette feuille de
route beaucoup plus précise qui nous
permettait d'aller plus vite peut-être
dans les mutualisations ce qu'on attend
justement de ces projets de territoire
c'est que nous puissions aussi faire des
économies en ligne parce que le but ce
n'est pas de faire des mille feuille
supplémentaire donc
tout ça va nous permettre certainement
d'améliorer encore la perfection qui est
saint quentin en yvelines et une force
tous ensemble c'est ça crée une force
des ambitions on a nommé
saint-quentin-en-yvelines terre
d'innovation
il faut qu'on s'en donne encore plus les
moyens qu'aujourd'hui donc on va y aller
c'est pour ça que j'ai envie de me
battre là dessus quand je dis me battre
c'est plutôt dans le sens de l'énergie
un c'est pas du tout dans le sens de
d'une polémique quelconque bien au
contraire
donc je vais suivre ça de près président
laugier m'a donné cette responsabilité
que je lui avais demandé parce que
prioritairement je voulais travailler
sur le projet de territoire dès le
départ donc voilà je suis je suis ravi
de m'en occuper et puis on verra bien on
se reverra dans quelques mois il on fera
certainement un fil rouge de
communication pour vous dire où ça en
est qu'est ce qu'on fait et nous serons
là
mais pour finir vous êtes visionnaire
aller dans 30 ans vous le voyez comment
50 ans je ne serai peut-être plus là je
le vois comme une vraie pépite au niveau
de l'île de france on a un potentiel de
développement économique extraordinaire
on est en train de mettre en place des
transports je dirais du 21e siècle
aussi on est dans ces prospectives là et
on veut surtout maintenir tous nos
espaces de vie et notre espace vert on a
deux jeunes ce soir qui vont intérieur
intervenir sur scène et qui vont parler
un peu de ce qu'ils attendent du projet
de territoire dans les 30 années à venir
et je pense que c'est à eux qu'il faut
poser la question parce que c'est pour
eux qu'on le fait
et bien je vous remercie merci on
poursuit ce set 8 invités avec nina
miolane bonsoir nina miolane vous avez
26 ans est originaire de billancourt et
vous êtes chercheuse au sein de l'équipe
asklepios de l'institut national de la
recherche en informatique et en
automatique de sophia antipolis aussi
appelé l inria et vous êtes ici ce soir
parce que vous êtes l'une des lauréates
du des bourses au real l'oréal unesco
pour les femmes et la science
un prix qui récompense des travaux sur
un modèle numérique de cerveau humain
j'ai pas dis une bêtise
rappelons peut-être que c'est que ces
bourses récompense uniquement des jeunes
chercheuses pas de jeunes chercheurs le
but c'est vraiment de mettre en avant le
travail des femmes chercheuses au
féminin oui c'est ça de mettre en avant
une forme de diversité en sciences que
c'est vrai que la science est un peu
accablée de stéréotypes
ouais même j'allais vous dire même le
monde de la recherche de la science et
est soumis aux mêmes clichés web 0
c'était donc on imagine tout de suite un
chercheur donc un homme dans un premier
temps blanc éventuellement avec les
cheveux en pétard des lunettes
on pense seulement à einstein et donc ce
programme essaye de mettre en avant des
profils différents et se bat contre un
stéréotype qui est celui que les femmes
ne peuvent faire de alors vous avez été
récompensé pour vos travaux sur
l'anatomie numérique
est-ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer
très simplement et très concrètement ce
que c'est oui alors à lui n'a rien on
travaille sur un modèle nato nîmes
numérique et plus précisément dans le
cas de mon équipe
un modèle de cerveau numérique cerveau
numérique donc en fait les hôpitaux nous
donne des images de cerveau humain donc
des images des patients qui viennent de
scanner ou une irm
on prend toutes ces images ont fait une
grosse moyenne avec l'ordinateur
donc on obtient le cerveau typique en
bonne santé
le cerveau parfait voilà l'essence
parfait s'il se sert à quoi d'avoir ce
cerveau parfait massa les applications
en médecine donc par exemple on peut
imaginer dans un futur proche si un
nouveau patient arrive à l'hôpital on va
pas pouvoir prendre une image de son
cerveau donc une irm de son cerveau à
lui qu'on va comparer à notre modèle
numérique de cerveau humain
et s'il est trop différent du modèle de
cerveau en bonne santé peut calculer la
probabilité que le patient a une maladie
neurodégénérative d'accord et on pourra
savoir précisément avec ce modèle qui
est lequel maladie et peut-être sujet le
patient ou pas du tout ça permettra de
savoir uniquement voilà attention alerte
il ya possibilité d'être malade voilà
donc la probabilité que le patient est
une maladie où on espère peut-être faire
de la médecine préventif un traitement
un diagnostic plus précoce
c'est à dire donné la probabilité qu'ils
développent la maladie dans le futur
donc on tend vers la médecine très
symptomatique
c'est diagnostiqué par exemple alzheimer
avant que la personne est là
de mémoire au quotidien expliquez-nous
concrètement vous nous avez vaguement
expliqué sur avec les irm les images
comment comment vous travaillez au
quotidien comment qu'est ce que vous
faites comment vous rassembler toutes
ses sources pour ensuite faire le
cerveau parfait si je puis me permettre
alors il ya plusieurs étapes c'est ce
qui est génial avec l'anatomie numérique
c'est que c'est très pure et
disciplinaires ça va des mathématiques
pures à l'informatique à l'imagerie
médicale et à la médecine donc sur un
peu de tout ça il ya des jours je fais
des maths pur donc papier crayon essayer
de prouver que l'algorithme qu'on
utilise la fonctionner correctement
il yad autres jours je prends les images
de cerveau j'ai implémente ce que j'ai
écrit en maths mais dans l'ordinateur et
je vois si ça rend un modèle de cerveau
en bonne santé
en termes de calendrier le cerveau
parfait va sortir quand en tout cas le
cerveau parfait en format numérique
c'est un projet qui avance vous en êtes
où alors ça c'est une question difficile
parce que justement la beauté de la
recherche c'est qu'on ne sait pas
toujours ce qu'on est en train de
chercher mais on est ouvert voilà on
découvre on est ouvert à à découvrir
plein de choses je pense que c'est en
terme de dizaines d'années la bourse de
la fondation l'oréal qui s'élève à peu
près à 15000 euros je crois pour vous là
bas vous savez à quoi poursuivre votre
recherche ou alors c'est pour un cadre
personnel donc à deux choses oui
dans un premier temps à poursuivre mes
recherches et dans mon cas à suivre une
formation très courte en neurosciences
juste pour pouvoir communiquer avec les
médecins juste pour apprendre le
vocabulaire et comprendre quel est le
besoin dans la médecine aujourd'hui
cette formation vous servira au sud
ensuite pour vos recherches ville pour
pouvoir mieux collaborer en fait parce
que moi je parle pas leur langage il
parle pas mon langage
donc c'est vrai qu'on a besoin de ça
pour communauté dans une récente
interview à nos collègues de la presse
écrite toutes les nouvelles de
versailles vous disiez également vouloir
mettre en place des ateliers qui
permettent de mélanger arts et sciences
ce que vous pouvez m'expliquer ça assez
rapides donc c'est ce à quoi j'espère
utiliser la deuxième partie de la bourse
à ce pouvoir communiquer sur les
sciences auprès des plus jeunes et leur
montrer que n'importe qui peut faire des
sciences et que la science est belle
donc en particulier je pense à une
expérience de l'aude hologram
par exemple avec
les all all ends essayer de leur montrer
ça est créée en fait une expérience
visuelle vous voyez par exemple une
baleine sortir du sol de la salle de
classe par hologram merci à nina miolane
d'avoir répondu à nos questions et bravo
pour cette belle pour cette bourse c'est
la fin de ce cette 8è les invités
nouvelle édition demain à la même heure
en attendant retrouvez toutes nos
séquences sur tv fil 78 points comme
bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]